foreign
ER based in Chicago
and two months ago I represented a
Vietnamese immigrant woman in her
divorce
as she was testifying about how her
husband brutally raped her the judge
repeatedly told her to stop speaking she
should only speak when I asked her a
question
can you imagine having to publicly share
one of the most painful traumatic
moments in your life and being told over
and over again to basically shut up
it felt so wrong
but also so familiar for me my mother
she had no say in her divorce she didn't
have a lawyer so she signed papers
giving away everything because she
thought she would otherwise be deported
back to Vietnam
I thought by becoming a lawyer I could
help people like my mother
but then I realized I was actually part
of the problem
as lawyers we take over speaking for our
clients and courtroom procedures Rules
of Evidence means that we have all the
power in what happens in their cases
we take terrible situations from
people's lives and we translate it into
legal language
but in doing so we rewrite our clients
as caricatures the most helpless most
victimized versions of themselves
this is the American legal system
and that's why eight years ago I founded
Beyond legal aid in the belief that it
doesn't have to be this way and lawyers
can actually change it working within
making it so that clients can speak for
themselves
how does this work
first instead of working nine to five in
offices downtown we travel go to our
clients where they live and during
evenings nights and weekends when
they're available and they can be active
participants in the legal process
next
let me share a little secret
well at least for the non-lawyers
attorneys like to be in charge
we go to law school we hang up fancy law
degrees and we wear fancy suits
obviously much fancier than what I'm
wearing because we want to be in control
but it's our clients whose lives are
being judged
and impacted by what I do
they need to be full Partners in charge
of their own cases
we can give advice Empower them to
navigate the legal system but ultimately
we need to follow their lead
and defer to their decisions
let me give you an example
one of our clients let's call him
Atticus
he was facing deportation in a case
where the law was completely against us
Atticus had been in iced attention for
several months because the immigration
judge denied him Bond
so he and ocad the organized communities
against deportation the community group
we were working with on his case wanted
to try for Bond a second time
I and the other lawyers were like no no
no no no no no you can't do that
the law is bad the judge has already
said no once and we don't want to piss
him off by questioning his decision
but they wanted to proceed so we
deferred to their decision
however
instead of my sharing his situation on
his behalf
we convince the judge to hear a live
conversation between Atticus and his U.S
Citizen's son
let's call him gem
Jim spoke about how he wanted to commit
suicide
because he couldn't live without his
father anymore
Atticus broke down sobbing in despair
because he felt responsible for what was
happening with his son and yet couldn't
be there for him
the judge was forced to hear directly
how Atticus and Gem loved each other and
how much they needed each other
he heard it unadulterated in full
without any questions without any
interruptions by any lawyers
unfortunately he denied Bonn a second
time
but
and of course there's a butt right
otherwise I wouldn't be telling you this
story
the judge then canceled atticus's
deportation
I cannot tell you how utterly absolutely
shocking that legal victory was
I
I was like oh my God I can't believe
this happened
and
I'm gonna say something now which
lawyers don't say very often but
probably should say a lot more often
I was wrong
my client and his community they knew
better
if we had not followed their lead and
tried for Bond a second time the judge
would have never heard Atticus tell his
own story and be so moved by what was
going on that he defied the law
to allow Atticus to stay in the country
with his son
Atticus being able to tell his own story
create a decision that was impossible at
least what we thought as attorneys
Atticus sharing and talking his own case
created Justice where the law was wrong
and that's why the legal system has to
change so that people like Atticus can
share their own stories have agency over
their own cases
in the meantime we as lawyers need to
make it happen in our work in our cases
right now
thank you